hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled immunoprotective versus
immunopathogenic responses
during fungal associated allergic airway
inflammation
the webinar is a part of the
microbiology
virtual week virtual event now
um i am sabrina lamoose of lab roots and
i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and sponsored by luminex for
more information about luminex go to
www.luminxcorp.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like
during the presentation to do so to
simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr chad
steele
professor excuse me professor and chair
department
of microbiology and immunology at tulane
university for a complete biography on
our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of
your screen dr steele welcome you may
now begin your presentation
okay thank you sabrina um it's a
good afternoon or good morning depending
on where you are everybody
um so as brittany said i have this
presentation today immunoprotective
versus immunopathogenic responses during
fungal association
allergic airway inflammation are also
known as
simply fungal asthma um i want to first
thank luminex for
sponsoring this presentation and also to
tyler and to sabrina
from lab roots for all their help in
hosting the uh
this uh workshop so i first want to
start off and just kind of you know give
you some
some definitions of what we talk about
we talk about asthma it's actually a
very simple disease in terms of
explanation but obviously it's much more
complex than
what this slide is going to show what it
simply is is inflammation in the airways
that leads to a decline in lung function
and so what you have here in this
cartoon is a picture of
an airway a healthy airway or normal
airways on the left
and then you have a disease or or an
airway undergoing an asthmatic attack on
the far right and you can see how
the lumen of the airway is much smaller
it's been um you know inflamed
uh it's uh it's got mucus in it things
like that and then that's that's how we
have a uh
i would have a uh a defect in our in our
pulmonary function when our airways get
like that
uh how many people have it so in the us
it's about 25 million people so roughly
uh one in 12 this includes adults and
kids
about 300 million worldwide and then
from the standpoint of a health care
cost it's actually quite significant
about 82 billion a year
in the us alone that essentially rivals
cancer health care costs
in the u.s as well um so when we talk
about asthma we talk about
two main things a phenotype of asthma
and an endotype of asthma
so a phenotype is really you know an
observable combination
of these various clinical biological
physiological uh
characteristics uh you can see here that
you have adult onset asthma you have
childhood asthma
a big component of asthma probably
two-thirds of asthma is considered the
large
asthma where you have allergies to a
variety of different things
such as you know cats or dogs or trees
or pollen
obviously in this case we're talking
about individuals who are allergic to
fungi
and then a lot of other different types
of asthma you know infection related air
pollution
you have exercise induced asthma these
are all basically common phenotypes of
asthma
but then you have to get to even more
detail when you talk about the
endotypes the endotypes is really the
actual mechanism that contributes to
your disease pathogenesis
and so you can see over here on the
right early onset
allergic asthma is often mediated by the
antibody ige
uh it's also mediated by the type 2 or t
helper 2 cytokines such as il-4 and
il-13
il-5 you can have eosinophilic asthma
you can have neutrophilic asthma there's
a lot of different types
and the reason why it's important to
understand endotypes and why we
uh you know segment aspirin into these
is that studying of endotypes has
actually brought about
you know some of the most promising
therapeutics we have for treating asthma
you can see on this slide over there on
the uh
on the left and the red boxes these are
all the type two cytokines and the
type two immune responses associated
with ige generation
and we have quite a few biologics or
anti-cytokine or anti-cytochrome
receptor antibodies
that have a have a huge effect on the
severity of disease and
and can ameliorate much of the symptoms
and the exacerbations
that are associated with asthma some
newer ones that are coming on board that
are in clinical trials now
include the ones in the middle uh you
know things that target tslp or il-33 or
il-25
these are pro-allergic pro-type 2 uh
inducing cytokines that that drive
uh these type 2 and th2 responses but
the caviar
is is that this is the pathway while
very well represented in asthma and is
clearly a causative pathway in disease
severity
and pathogenesis um most of these
biologic at least everyone on this page
really only targets
that type 2 th2 response and so
obviously some asthma is not type 2 or
ts2 it could be
interfering gamma driven or type 1 th1
driven it could be il17 driven
type 17 or th17 driven and so
you know we have to really drill down
into individual asthmatic endotypes to
figure out what
component is driving that response and
can it be targeted so that's really kind
of been some of the goals of our
research
over the last eight to ten years
so when we talk about what we're
specifically investigating in the lab
it's really
allergic asthma as it relates to fungal
sensitization
so this has a variety of terms in
literature severe asthma with fungal
sexualization is one term
fungal asthma is another term fungal
associated allergic arrow inflammation
and what you can see here on the left is
really kind of the standard
of blood test that you would run in an
allergist
office or an immunologist's office
clinically this is the panel that we
would look at
from the standpoint of what you're
allergic to is so we can kind of figure
out you know what your triggers are you
know and things like that
and you can see in the red boxes i have
three fungi
uh that are very common in asthma
pathogenesis and in asthma allergy
um that we that we routinely test for uh
one of those being aspergillus fumigatus
which is the organism that i've worked
on for about 15 years
and the one we're going to be talking
about today so if you're an asthmatic
and you're sensitized to
um a fungi aspergillus or altenaria or
codosporium or pelicillium
uh what does that mean well oftentimes
you have a poorly controlled asthma
um you know it you know from this most
severe asthmatics it ranges anywhere
from 15 to 45
it's usually uh younger onset of disease
so childhood
your ige levels are often higher than it
is for other sensitivities other
allergen sensitivities you usually use
steroids much more often
and you also have more exacerbations and
more hospitalizations
now it's rare to see an individual
that's only allergic to fungi you're
usually allergic to
a lot of these different things you
could be alerted to anywhere
six eight or ten of these at one time
but there are some that appear to be
more
dominant dominant than others um and a
lot of times when we look at our data we
do look at
asthmatics that are allergic to some
things but just not
aspergillus or alton area and then we
compare those two asthmatics that are
allergic to all these different things
as well as
the various fungi so this
was really our first foray into asthma
at least experimentally
um we developed an animal model um where
we take aspergillus
this is uh you know the it's the black
mold you see in your ceiling tile you
know things like that
um it's ubiquitous in the environment
it's in uh you know your carpet you know
it's in the ceiling tile you know things
like that you bring it in every day and
nobody really has any problems with it
but if you do uh get some level of
reactivity to it
obviously a sensitivity with high ig
type 2 cytokines things like that you
can result into this reactive airway
disease
and so we don't use any um any allergens
we actually use the live fungal
organisms that's what you breathe in
every day
we um we also don't use any adjectives
to skew the immune response one way or
the other we just uh
just really just uh treat the mice or
challenge the mice with the organism so
that's our
our um our our uh our timeline there
where we basically give a dose of day
zero
we wait a week and then we challenge
five days in a row
wait a couple of days three more times
and then we sacrifice animals
uh in this case mice on day 17 and
that's when we do all of our
inflammatory and physiological
uh measurements and so as i said this
was the first study that we did
going on eight years ago now um we were
interested in this
uh this pattern recognition receptor
called dectin one which is a fungal beta
glucan receptor
and we basically had published
previously that in an in an infection
model this receptor was
required for clearing the organism from
the lung and required
for um all the inflammatory responses
and things like that
but in asthma it's actually bad so
signaling through dectin 1 during a
chronic exposure
um results in worse lung function which
you can see the top
right graph um and um
you can see that other components that
are decay independent include
the uh the text in blue the mach 5 ac
goblet goblin expression uh chemo
conscious of ccl17 ccl22 which are
critical for
uh recruiting type 2 cells for the lung
il-33 some inflammatory meteors such as
il1 beta and
n6 cl1 as well as uh neutrophil all that
was dependent on detecting one excuse me
and we also ultimately ascribe this to
the cytokine il-22
which is an il-10 family member it's
part of the type 17 responses with il17a
and essentially mice that were deficient
in il-22 phoenix copied the detective
one knockouts
and uh incidentally provided us a
therapeutic target and so if you see the
bottom graph there you can see that when
we treat mice
with an antibody against il-22 we can
modulate the severity
of their asthma as measured by uh
one function so this is our initial
foray into
experimental asthma and one question
that we had you know a year so after
this paper was published
was you know can we get insight from
human patients so human asthmatics
that are sensitized to fungi can they
tell us
something about their disease that we
can you know bring back to our animal
model and interrogate
some pathways and mediators and things
like that um
that could be contributing to the
severity of asthma and so we reached out
to a group at
wake forest who was part of the uh this
heart lung and blood institute severe
asthma research program this was a
program that was funded for
quite a few years between 2000 2017 it
was multiple sites around the us
and they enrolled uh quite a few
asthmatics um
and phenotyped these individuals and so
ultimately about 35 percent of these
asthmatics had uh
had some um positivity or some
sensitizations of specific ige or
skin test reactivity to fungi you can
see in this table here this is comparing
uh some of these asthmatics that are
that were allergic
asthmatics or atopic asthmatics but
we're not fungal positives that's a
fungal negative category
versus those that were actually
sensitized to fungi you can see in the
bold area
that uh in a nutshell if you're a fungal
sensitizer fungal positive
you have worse lung function um you have
higher levels of
atp or allergic so your ige levels are
higher
you have higher eosinophils in your
blood um things like that and so
for all intensive purposes of the the if
you're fungal
if you're an asthmatic that's fungal
sensitive erasmus appears to be somewhat
worse
uh by all these different parameters and
so the question we ask
is can we you know uh you know look into
these
uh individuals and look at some samples
derived from the lung
uh and and and basically identify
potential
you know uh biomarkers or mediators that
are up regulated or or expressed or
produced at higher amounts
uh in these patients and then bring
those back to our animal model and see
if we can interrogate their role
so in our initial uh runs several years
ago we looked at
a bronco alameda lavage fluid from these
patients and we also looked at the
industrial from these patients and you
can see
um we did this by the uh by the luminex
reagent so this is the cytokine bead
array the multiplex system
um our machine is from from birad the
bioplex system and the kits we used in
this case were from
billy port or the miliplex kits so these
are the human panels that we use that
comprise
96 different analytes that we can
quantify at the
protein level and so we did that
and i'm going to break down quite a few
of these that we actually have now
pursued this is research like i said
that's been going on probably for six or
seven years
now this is uh some data that we
published about two years ago looking at
some of the differences in some of the
mediators that were
um that are different between fungal
positive and fungal negative
uh these are all mediators that we found
to be significantly
elevated in the human asthmatics that
were
that were sensitized to to the variety
of fungi
the one i have highlighted here is il-7
so il-7 is a
common gamma chain cytokine very
critical for
lymphocyte development um things of that
nature and we were actually interested
in il-7
or we were actually you know we had an
interest in il-7 actually
even before we found it in as well
because we had an interest in from our
previous depth in one aisle 22 paper we
had an interest in
trying to determine what cells were
actually making il-22 in the long-term
fungal asthma and at that time we had
some preliminary data
uh that suggested that it was some of
the innate like lymphocytes the gamma
delta t
cells the inkt cells uh those cells and
it turns out that
those cells require il-7 for homeostasis
and things of that nature so it was
interesting that il-7 came up
on our initial um you know biomarker
assessment
in these uh in these human asthmatics
and so essentially what we showed so
this is basically the raw data on the
left showing the il-7 is elevated in
these fungal positive patients
and one thing that we were able to do
with this particular cytokine was
to show that it actually had this this
negative correlation with this pc20 so
pc20 is a lung function measurement
uh that is the concentration that is
required um
methacholine that's required to produce
a 20 percent drop in in fnv1 which is
another measure of lung function forced
extraordinary volume
and as you can see on this in the second
graph down at the bottom there that as
the il-7
cytokine concentration increases uh the
log
pc20 or the less drug it takes to
provoke this 20
drop and so it will suggest that il-7 is
potentially having some type of uh
adverse or pathogenic role um
in in fungal asphalt and so we basically
hypothesize from this
that um that these high il-7 or higher
il7 levels in these
fungal positive asthmatics may drop some
type of homeostatic or expansion
of cell populations um that produce some
factors and these factors
ultimately uh cause um uh asthma to
to exacerbate or to worsen uh in some
way
and so initially we uh we thought about
tackling this by um by
looking at animals that did not did not
make il-7 so an il-7 deficient mouse or
an il-7 knockout
it turns out those mice really can't get
asthma because they have a significant
defect in their lymphocyte population so
i simply a lot of the cells that cause
asthma um
are are absent or are significantly
lower amounts in those mice and so
that's not really the
right way to go we also thought about
taking the biologic
angle and neutralizing il-7 and we
actually
can't do that because one of the
interesting characteristics of the
common gamma chain family is that if you
actually neutralize them
with an antibody you actually extend
their half-life and make them more
potent
rather than blocking them which is
something we actually found the hard way
by treating mice with dial seven
our anti-il7 and making it worse and so
what we ultimately did is that we
ultimately decided let's just
try to elevate the level of io-7 during
experimental fungal asthma
and see what that would do and so we
ended up treating mice with il-7
and essentially we um use the exact same
model that we had before this is a that
we published a couple years ago
and basically if you give il-7 to mice
over the development of our fungal
asthma model
their lung function gets it's much much
worse uh it drives
um high levels of type 2 cytokines some
of the pro-allergic chemicals
that i mentioned earlier ccl17 ccl22
a lot of the inflammatory cytokines go
up um il-17 il-22 go
up uh you know increases in cellularity
so cd4 t cells estimate fills things of
that nature
this is the data that i've referred to
earlier looking at what cells were
making
il-22 so this is an il-22 reporter mouse
uh flow cytometry here on the right and
basically the quantified data is
this is control would be uh basically
mice that received
vehicle or pbs and then fa is fungal
asthma and you can see how
the ekt cells and the gamma delta t
cells um in the cd4 is actually kind of
expand
and this model and then down at the
bottom is actually
both sets of mice that are that are both
fungal asthma but one stream with a
vehicle and once treated with
recombinant il-7 and you can see how the
nkt cells
are dramatically increased as well as
the cd4 cells and so like i said these
spikes get um
much more severe asthma um
we did try to target this from a
therapeutic standpoint as i said we
can't do
anti-ill-7 as a therapy but we could
potentially block the receptor as a
therapeutic
and so we did try to block cb127 which
is the il-7 receptor
we were to mod we were to eight we were
able to modulate the
the immune little bit in these mice we
could lower the type 2 responses we
could lower the type
17 responses cellularity also was
modulatable
by anti-cd 127 treatment
but what was really interesting and
unexpected was we actually made the lung
function worse
even though the immunology per se got
better uh ahr
our airway hyper reactivity um our
airway resistance
got worse and we still to this day don't
necessarily know why that happened it
was actually a very consistent
observation
and it's something that we're uh that
we're still pursuing and trying to
understand why blocking that signaling
pathway for aisle seven
uh ended up uh ended up having a
decrement
in in one physiology so another couple
of
mediators that fell out of our analysis
initially in our human asthmatics
was il-1 beta and il-1ra our il-1
receptor antagonist which is the natural
antagonist for il-1 alpha and il-1 beta
signaling
these were both found to be elevated in
our um
in our human fungal positive asthmatics
and so this is the paper that we
published uh
just under a year ago looking at the
role of these and so we
looked at mice that were deficient in
the il1 receptor and as you can see on
the left the grafts
these mice actually have uh much
improved asthma this this is airway
resistance railway hyperactivity on the
top the bottom graph is
is another aspect of really whole lung
or total lung resistance the dynamic
lung resistance
and you can see that the uh the knockout
mice that don't have the il1 receptor
actually do much better
um and histologically you have um
basically an hd on top
and a pas stain that stains mucous on
the bottom and you can see in the wild
type miles
mice at least around the airways you see
a fair amount of inflammation that you
don't really see
in the il1 receptor knockouts and then
also in the wild types you see
um you know really evidence of asthma
with the the purple or the
the hot peak staining in the airway
which is the mucus and the
goblet cells and things like that that
are really hyperactive and you see
that at a much much lower level in the
um
in the i1 receptor knockout mice so it
appears that
signaling through the il1 receptor does
contribute to pathogenesis
and severity of um a fungal asthma
now what happens if you remove the
antagonists and so if you take mice that
are deficient in the
natural inhibitor of iowa and signaling
il1 receptor antagonist
you see the complete opposite phenotype
these mice get
much worse asthma they get uh the ahr so
the airway resistance is much higher in
these animals the total lung resistance
is much higher
and if you look at it histologically you
can take a pathologist to see that these
lungs are not looking too good so
h e again on the top pas thing ones on
the bottom
um what you end up seeing for the most
part in these il1 receptor antagonist
knockouts
um is really this massive inflammatory
response and
and almost an an obliterative lung
injury phenotype it almost looks like
pneumonia i mean this is a lot of
inflammation
the airways are completely clogged
almost to the point where you can't even
see the um
you know the hyperplasia or the mucous
production and everything just the
airways are just full of
all these inflammatory cells and so we
have this really interesting polar
opposite phenotype between
the il1 receptor knockouts and il1
receptor antagonist
knockouts and so that left us prom to
really kind of go after what the
immological you know mechanisms or
consequences were
uh in these mice and so the first thing
we looked at was you have to pretty much
look at type 2 or th2 responses and
eosinophil
um levels and things like that that's
the classic you know asphalt
pathogenesis
um um pathways you can see in the
receptors
knockouts on the left and the and the
receptor antagonist knockouts from the
right
on the left you see that actually the
receptor um
knockouts who have much improved asthma
or less severe asthma
have lower eosinophils uh the type two
responses were actually relatively
low um this model actually we published
before that it really induces everything
so type 1 type 2
type 17 all these responses are induced
and i would argue you could probably
uh individually neutralize any one of
those pathways and get some level of
efficacy
um as far as uh improving disease but
our bias is that it's really il17 and
il-22 that's the most immunopathogenic
in this model
but you know again we have to look at
type 2 just to just to determine you
know what the effects are on these
pathways
um you would expect that the receptor
antagonists because their lungs look
really really inflamed uh and because
their airway hyperactivity and their
lung function was really really poor
everything would be kind of through the
roof if you will at least from the tight
pitch standpoint we actually don't see
that
um the eosinophils were actually lower
they weren't higher which we would
probably expect
um some of the pro-allergic chemicals
were either no different or slightly
higher
um the th2 cytokines at least for il-4
and il5 were not
exacerbated they were actually lower now
il-33
was um was a little bit higher in these
in these mice again that that did not
correlate with the um
the uh the il4 and il5 levels but you
know it is considered you know an
effector and a prology
uh mediator and so um so that was
elevated but in general the type 2
responses
were not were not elevated in these
receptor antagonists
what was interesting is that we saw the
complete uh you know mirror image or the
flip-flop if you will of the type 17
responses so
once again the il1 receptor knockouts on
the left the receptor antagonist
knockouts on the right
and you can see that um that the
neutrophil levels were cut
by half at least in the receptor
knockouts the type 17
cytokines il-17 and io-22 were
significantly reduced
and um as well as some of the 17
dependent
mediators such as gcsf that was also you
know which is a growth factor for
neutrophils
that was also significantly reduced in
contrast in the receptor
antagonists this actually would what we
would
probably expect from the standpoint of
looking at the histology you can see the
neutrophils would dramatically increase
uh il-17 il-22 was not but il-17 was
also increased by four-fold
and the chemicals uh in gcsf that are
associated with neutrophil development
neutrophil hemotaxis
um were also elevated in these uh in
these animals and so
now we're starting to get a little bit
clearer picture of of some of the
immunopathogenic mechanisms that are
that are affecting fungal asthma in the
sense that you know it appears that it
could be neutrophil driven
and il-17 associated as well um
we also looked at type 1 responses this
is just again this is actually using
luminex technology but using it uh in in
the mouse
so this is a and actually a 32 plex kit
that we use
and you can see the um the receptor
knockout on top the receptor antagonists
on bottom
and again they completely flip um so uh
interfering gamma as well as the
interfering gamma associated chemicals
6 cl 9 and 6 cl10 were both
significantly lower in the receptor
knockouts
which again correlated with the more
improved asthma
or the veteran physiology whereas in the
receptor antagonists these were all
significantly exacerbated much much
higher levels
of these in the receptor knockout
and so one question that we had was you
know is this a targetable pathway can we
modulate this it kind of goes back to
when i introduced the biologics and how
how you know the asthma therapeutically
as a field we have a lot of biological
target type 2 can we develop
therapeutics or are there therapeutics
already developed
um that that we can employ to to to
target different pathways
and so this is uh kenaret or anakinra
which is actually human recombinant il1
receptor antagonist
this is not um a biologic per se but it
is a recombinant protein
that we got from uh that we got from
sobi and so this is basically looking at
lung function can we administer this
therapeutic
uh this is actually approved for other
inflammatory diseases
um but not for asthma but can we
administer
this and uh and affect uh or improve
lung function and indeed we can the top
is actually a really low dose of
anakinra uh so this is 10 milligram per
kilogram you can see
a little i mean it's significant but
that's not really a dramatic change in
lung functions it's lower but it's not
dramatic but if you increase this five
fold
uh to 50 milligrams per kilogram you do
see quite a
an improvement in in airway function um
in in the mice that received the uh the
anakinra
and so if you look at the immune
response in these animals what you do
see is actually there on the bottom uh
by blocking the il1 receptor signaling
we did not have any effect on the type 2
response but we did have an effect on
the type 1 response which is the
interfering
6 cl9 graph there on the left and also
il17 so the type 17 responses
on the right were significantly lower in
mice that received anti-kendra so it
does appear that this pathway is
targetable at least in experimental
asphalt obviously we have to do more
studies
in humans but this is definitely
something that i think could improve the
severity of disease
all right so finally another um mediator
see how we do it on time okay
um another mediator that that we um
that we also found was cx3cl1 so this is
also known as fractalcon um we uh
what i'm not showing here is that i'm
not showing any of the of the speedom
data but fractalcon was
was also elevated in sputum from fungal
positive human asthmatics and so we
wanted to
interrogate the role of uh fractal con
so these are mice that are deficient in
the receptor for fractal constipation
are one deficient animals
we expected these mice to probably have
improved asthma if these
uh if this pathway was driving some
type of inflammatory you know
chemotactic event i mean it is a
chemokine
um but much to our surprise actually the
opposite is true
these mice actually have uh worse asthma
so
when you don't have uh the receptor when
you don't have
uh 63cl1 signaling or fractal
concentration
actually the mice do do poor they have
worse asthma
on and you could see here the wild type
in the uh
and the fractal kind of receptor
knockouts um again
uh that take a pathologist to see that
that's a pretty bad
lung there the airway is completely
occluded lots of inflammation all over
the place and so again you know another
very very strong
physiological phenotype and histological
phenotype
um that can really provide us some
answers as to what's going on from the
immological
or immunopathogenesis perspective and so
we did just that and so
it turns out uh you know based on our
il1 studies you know we knew that
that neutrophils are likely a pathogenic
component in this
uh in this airway disease the fungal
associated um
awareness gateway inflammation uh and
indeed they're significantly higher
in the uh in the in the fracticon
receptor knockouts
uh il-17 is also dramatically higher
gcsf
again we show this in the il-1 receptor
antagonist these are all higher
uh the chemicals that we usually look at
as far as recruitment of neutrophils to
the lung were elevated
and then just inflammation in general
tnf i1 alpha il-1 beta
those are also elevated in these
fracticon
deficient animal fracticon receptor
efficient animals so
really a heightened really really
heightened inflammatory
response but it's not just restricted to
um
neutrophils it turns out the type 2 and
the esd fields are also elevated so
uh eosinophils up on the top left graph
were also significantly increased
il5 was uh slightly higher i mean you
know it's a long scale it's not a huge
difference but
il5 is obviously critical for essential
survival so um so that's elevated um
ccl11 which is the common chemical for
uh for recruiting using fields actually
was not
different uh the type two cytokines io
four trended higher il13 was higher
ccl5 which in some scenarios can also
promote
um eosinophil recruitment was elevated
um but some of the other pro-allergic
markers that we've looked at in the past
that can be
modulated uh in in asthma severity or
fungalized austerity
in the bottom right il-33 ccl17 and
ccl22
were not modulated um in the absence of
the fractal con
receptors we also looked at type one
again because uh you know we think this
could be playing a role at least based
on our data from the il1
receptor and i1 receptor antagonist uh
story we think that that
type 1 responses also contribute to
asthma severity and once again
you see that these appear to be
exacerbated to a certain degree um
we look at inflammatory monocyte levels
and those are significantly increased
they're not as high as
uh on a per cell number as the
eosinophils and nutrients but they are
elevated um
the classic chemical that recruits um
inflammatory monocytes is a ccl2 we
actually
not see any differences uh to explain
the increase in the inflammatory
monocyte numbers and the fracticon
receptor knockouts
but we did see a little bit higher
levels of mcsf which could be a
stabilization or
or um you know generation factor for
these uh these cell types or some data
out there suggesting that
that both gm csf and mcs are critical
for the survival of inflammatory
monocytes and so
that could be an explanation we're not
we're not 100 sure about that but that
could be a possibility
that could explain why the uh the
inflammatory monocytes are elevated in
these uh
in these animals um so
obviously with everything really kind of
being haywire in these mice and it was
uh
you know significantly inflamed at
multiple levels type 1 type 2 type 17
type 17 you would think that maybe
something's wrong with their
anti-inflammatory mechanisms and so we
looked at a variety of those
and really didn't find anything um you
know we did uh t-rex up on the left not
really any differences there
il-10 was uh significantly higher rather
than
lower we didn't see anything um anything
there
il-35 and il-38 are both um you know
starting to become a little bit more
appreciated uh as an immunoregulatory
cytokines minor regulatory factors
um that are uh that could potentially
regulate
the magazine of inflammation uh in a
variety of diseases as well as asthma
not a ton of data known about these in
asthma but uh but people are starting to
look at them and
as you can see they're not really
different either so um whatever the
you know i'm sure there's other
mechanisms we could look at you know tgf
beta and things like that but
um but in general you know at least you
know some of the more prevalent
um anti-inflammatory mechanisms were
actually not
affected by the absence of fractal kind
of receptor signaling and so
right now we're still not completely
clear exactly what the mechanism is of
this
of this dysregulation you know what why
does fractal con
signaling uh you know result or why
what does the lack of fractal concept
result in this really hyperinflammatory
response
and worse uh worst fungal asthma um
one thing that you might have recognized
is if you look at the fractal kind of
receptor knockouts
they actually look very very close to
the il1
receptor antagonist knockouts both of
these bicep
really bad uh airway hyperactivity and
they have obviously a lot of
inflammation
um which would suggest that maybe this
mechanism is associated with
uh maybe a lack of il1 receptor
antagonist unfortunately that was not
the case actually i one
was increased in these mice which
actually marries
well with the high il-1 beta il-1 alpha
data because those are elevated in these
mice and usually in that scenario il-1
receptor antagonist
is also induced as a check and balance
for all one
uh sibling but so that's not the
mechanism here we're kind of hoping it
was but that ended up not being
uh something that we could uh we could
hang the hat on so
so to switch gears a little bit here on
the last
few slides um you know one thing we've
gotten interested in over the last
several years
is um chitin uh and so chitin
you know after uh cellulose is the
second most you know
common uh compound or molecule really in
the environment um you know it's a major
component of
fungal cell wall including aspergillus
insects so house dust mite is a common
uh allergic asthma allergen
uh cockroaches in it is a uh is also an
allergic
acid allergen uh chitin is very
prevalent in the
in the uh in the exoskeletons of these
animals um
you know crab and crawfish and shrimp
and things like that all have kite in
their show off
um and so basically you know we've we've
developed um over time you know enzymes
that
are used to to to break these things
down these are called chitinases
and then we have other things called
kinase like proteins that can bond
chitin
but actually do not have any enzymatic
activity uh
in the um but they can't bond and uh you
know sequester or block if you will
uh you know kite and reactivity and so
basically the blue
uh there's two known mammalian kite
bases acidic membrane kite indexes
or except acidic mammalian kitinis and
then kyto triostomies
these are the two that are known to have
enzymatic activity and can actually
break down chitin
and then there's quite a few of other
kitings like proteins probably the most
well-recognized one in asthma
is ykl 40 uh which again does not have
the enzymatic activity but can
bond to uh can bond to uh to chitin
and so we got interested in this because
well for one we were already interested
in
you know beta glucans in the fungal cell
wall and how their recognition could
drive immunopathogenesis or drive
severity of disease
that was the very first paper that we
did and that was the first thing that i
showed at the start of the talk
um and so we speculated that there were
other things in the fungal cell wall
that were also
immunoreactive but could also
potentially drop pathogenesis
and uh chitin was obviously uh one of
those and so
if you look at kite and asthma there's
actually it's not as many papers as you
would
think per se probably you know a couple
hundred you know maybe not even that
high
um but chitin really is a buzzword in
asthma pathogenesis
and um you know this is just a handful
that i that i've thrown out uh here
probably need to update this list this
is just a handful
of uh of papers that are kind of related
chitin to pathogenesis
of uh of asthma uh or at least um
um you know some airway hyperactivity
disease if you will
however you really have to dig into
these papers to really understand what
they're what they're testing and it
turns out
um they might not be as thorough as they
as they
as they you know portray you know and
you can see here in the blue that
you know some of these are really not
testing
uh you know um you know chitin per se
maybe they're
you know adding it onto an another
asthma model like for example
ova um you know there's a couple of
these papers that actually
give um chitin uh coated beads
uh some of these only give it once or
twice and then analyze airway
function and um you know inflammatory
you know mechanisms and things like that
but it's not really a chronic
administration you know and asthma by
definition
is a chronic disease and it's a chronic
exposure so
so you know getting um you know you know
interpreting these results from the
standpoint of these very acute
challenges
might not be as as simple or as as
robust as it would be have these
challenges
done you know in a much more chronic
fashion like we do
for our fungal ash bottle with
aspergillus um
so we had shown uh in one of our earlier
papers this was going on 15 years ago
now so this is just a cartoon with a
fungal cell wall
and all the different carbohydrates and
things that make up this cell wall
you can see that the the bulk of the
cell wall probably 60 percent of it is
made up of these fungal beta glucans so
that's the green and the blue and green
kind of interspersed all over
on that fungal cell wall and then the
pink circles are actually
uh chitin so these are the kite
parameters and you can see that
these are you know relatively deeper
buried if you will kind of in the uh
in the fungal cell wall um and what we
had shown a few years ago with
beta glucans is that these actually
become unmasked and so if you take
aspergillus and just culture it in vitro
and then stain for
fungal beta glucan you can actually see
that early on you know two hours you get
a kind of a pump take standing not a
whole lot and then by the time they
start to swell
uh these kineti we actually call them
swollen canadia they're
significantly swollen and round and
probably four to five times larger
um you can see that the beta glucans are
actually very easily exposed
once these organisms start to hyphenate
uh by 10 hours
um again very high levels of beta-glucan
exposure but then by the time they fully
hyphenate and they
turn into these these yeti-like
structures the mycelium you can see
they're still beta-glucan
positive but at a much lower level than
they were earlier so these
beta-glucan moldings become unmasked
over time and then they
essentially remast or down-regulate or
whatever they do
uh to where they're not as um as exposed
and so we speculated that because chitin
was so
deep in the cell wall of fungi that this
was probably going to happen
similarly to what it does for many
glucans and indeed that's exactly what
does happen so if you look at
uh specific uh you know things that
sting titans and wheat german gluten and
this is a reagent called capricorn white
uh this is over a relatively short
period of time zero to eight hours
um you can see that by the time they
hyphenate up to
uh eight to ten hours here you can see a
nice titan stain you don't really see
that early on in the zero to two hour
you know the chemical floor white was a
little bit more sensitive
um in detecting the uh the uh kite and
moldies and the aspergillus cell wall
you can see the blue at the bottom
how they their appears to uh you know
start out roughly around two hours and
really it's kind of going pretty good by
eight hours you can see the chitin um
um emerging from the uh from the cell
wall if you will as
these organisms go through metabolic and
biochemical um
changes and so uh you know we became
interested in chitin
um and this is a paper that we published
about two years ago
actually looking at amp case or acidic
mammalian kitinase
and uh what we would expect is that you
know
having the inability to break down
chitin
would result in some type of uh maybe
accumulation event
to where chitin would be in the airways
for a longer period of time and would
provoke an immune response you know
essentially make asthma worse
and we uh we actually did not see that
at all we actually saw the opposite and
that mice that are deficient in
acetaminophen actually have better lung
function so they have lower airway
resistance
immunologically there was not a lot to
really um
focus on we did see some of the
pro-allergic chemicals that we
constantly look at
were lower and uh probably the most the
most uh
fitting thing was that lower aisle 17a
and il 22 for the type
17 responses were um were lower
um you know we didn't see really any
changes in the type one response there's
really any differences in type one or
the type twos
uh uh in these mics and you know you can
see in the airways
a little a little bit um you know
less inflammation as far as cellularity
um
as well as some of the mucus production
and things like that
um but kind of opposite of what we what
we expected um
so you know we're in the process of kind
of verifying the chitin accumulation and
things like that in these mice
and looking at that but it did not
appear that uh
that the lack of breaking down chitin at
least by this one uh kitenase did not uh
you know it was actually um more
pathogenic if you will to have this
thing expressed then that did not happen
um so we also got interested in uh ykl40
and mice this is called brp
39 uh and one of the reasons why we got
interested in this is kind of going back
to our human asthmatic
profile the biomarkers that we looked at
ykl 40 was one of the ones that was on
that 96
a mediator panel and it was elevated
actually in
human asthmatics that were fungal posted
suggesting maybe that the rp39 is an
immunopathogenic factor
in um uh in human human fungal asthma as
well as potentially experimental fungi
so we wanted to interrogate
that um and once again you know
this is where science gets really
exciting you think something's gonna
happen the opposite happens and it
happens routinely
and reproducibly and then you're like
okay this is definitely something that
needs to be pursued
and so we we got mice that are deficient
in this kindness
protein vrp39 um
and you can see that almost like the
fractal con receptor knockouts almost
like the il1 receptor antagonist
knockouts
these mice have much worse asthma much
higher air rate resistance
to their every physiology is worse and
so
we start kicking off the boxes and
saying okay what are the mechanisms here
this is probably going to be
immunological let's start going through
uh actually one of the first things that
we looked at based on some of the
literature
searches with brp 39 which is actually
not widely
um investigated in that but there's a
couple of papers on old valve human and
a couple of papers on house dust mite
um that show that this uh actually um
uh the mice that are deficient in the
rp39 actually do better they have
less severe asthma in those allergen
models so actually completely option
ours um and so one of the first things
we ask is what about mucus production
maybe that's different between these
mice
uh it turns out it doesn't look like it
at least histologically you can look at
the airway there with the purple
staining and
roughly looks the same between wild type
and knockout we actually
uh quantified this by looking at uh mach
5ac and gob5 or clca
um expressing and you can see there's
really no difference this is just
real-time pcr measurements
of these and how long we didn't really
see any differences in the mucous
production
um another thing that we uh don't
normally look at but did in this case
was pulmonary edema in that maybe these
mice have more edema
um and so that's what's driving their
airway hyper reactivity
um and you can see that that does not
really be the case it's actually the
opposite they have less pulmonary edema
even though they have worse fungal
asthma
um even actually the baseline even in
naive mice they seem to have
a lower with the wet to dry um lung
weight
uh and so um so the the pulmonary demon
does not appear to be a potential
mechanism
so what about the um inflammation or the
immune responses and as you can see um
here
um uh if you look in the uh
this is hd stained lungs you can see
that
really not a massive difference maybe a
little bit less of
inflammatory cells in the um in the uh
in the brp 39 uh deficient animals but
not a whole lot of difference we
actually did flow on these on these
animals to identify the cell populations
uh
actually neutrophils which we always
have followed our pathogenic in fungal
asthma
or trended lower but we're not
significant we did find lower
eosinophils and we did find lower cd4 t
cells
um so again completely not what we would
expect based on the loan physiology brp
39 deficient animals have worse airway
hyper reactivity we expected that to
correlate with
higher cellularity and higher
inflammation not
lower because we've seen these
coordinates in our previous couple of
data sets that i've already shown you
but these are actually lower
if you go into type 1 type 2 type 17 and
phenotype all of these responses
type 1 type 17 no difference at all
type 2 lower actually uh significantly
lower
4 5 33 the chemo concept we always look
at
um all of these are lower so really
really
confusing data i mean this really does
not make sense based on the airway
uh hyper reactivity um and so you know
we can not really you know at this point
call this amino pathogenic because
there's nothing that's really going
haywire in these animals to explain
why this this um
area hyperactivity is so high um we've
started looking at some of the
anti-inflammatory mechanisms again maybe
they're
you know dysregulated somehow that
doesn't appear to be the case again
il-10 t-jet pain is actually lower
il-38 actually is higher in these
animals
um and maybe you know that could explain
why some of the type 2 responses are
lower because
il-38 is a negative regulator of those
that might explain it but again that
does not explain why the lung physiology
uh in these mice is so much higher and
so much worse so again
not really any major immune coordinates
that can explain this and so
the next thing that we did is well maybe
we can isolate the function of brp-39
in a cell type or or you know a group of
cells that will help us understand
you know what could be going on and so
we did what they call bone marrow
chimaeras where you irradiate mice and
then you give them back you know bone
marrow either from the same mouse or
different house
to basically isolate brp-39 expression
either in the immune or the
hematopoietic compartment or in the
non-immune or non-hematopoietic
compartment and so we did this
and unfortunately it did not reveal uh
anything completely uh clear it turns
out that if you have vrp39 expressed
either in an immune cell or in a
non-immune cell
such as an airway epithelial cell or an
airway smooth muscle cell
that's sufficient to protect the animal
from airway hyperactivity and so uh we
have all the groups here all the
controls and whatnot
you can see that knockout into knockout
which is just another you know vrp is
not expressed anywhere
really bad you know airway hyperactivity
really bad asthma and then if you
actually knock it out in either the
immune anonymity department
um so that you know did not help us
narrow down potential
uh mechanisms to explain this um and so
where we're at now
is you know one thing you know that we
try to do a lot of our research is
trying to
you know look at this from a therapeutic
targeting standpoint um
we figured you know well let's see let's
just see if we can treat mice just
normal mice
rather than knock out with prp uh and
um let's see if we can modulate uh the
severity of fungal asthma
and this is all this is a preliminary
study we just
did we have another one coming off
actually tomorrow i think um looking at
this and so these are just normal wild
type mice that are
that have asthma that are treated with
brp39 uh
and it does appear that we can actually
lessen disease severity
um by treating with this uh this
kindness-like
protein we don't know what the mechanism
is um chances are it's not going to be
immune based based on our knockout data
but
at the very least this gives us another
avenue to pursue from the standpoint of
of uh what is really going on in these
animals uh as far as
uh how brp 39 functions to protect
against the severity of
experimental fungal asthma so just to
wrap
up last slide or two and everything i i
think what i wanted to convey here is
that we actually
were you know really a basic science
mouse lab and we have the opportunity
to look into humans and try to get some
some biomarkers and we use luminex
technology to do this
to get biomarkers uh that we could
really you know do the
rather than the bits the bedside we
actually did bedside to bench and
got the human data uh to tell us what we
needed to go back and look at in the
mouse model
and as you can see this is just some of
the data that's fallen out of this
that we've kind of broadly broken these
down that you know some of these
pathways
um you know were immunopathogenic we
actually speculated on that
anything that was elevated in a human um
would correlate to you know would be
immunopathogenic would be bad it turns
out we're
that's not the case so il1 sibling is
bad il1 receptor antagonist remember
that was elevated in humans
but actually you know you want that to
be elevated because without it
uh asthma gets worse uh am case um again
uh expected that to uh to decrease
severity actually
uh it contributes to disease uh brp 39
um don't know the mechanism but
uh and again can't say it's
immunoprotective per se
um but it clearly is required to to
protect the lung from airway
hyperactivity and then
i didn't go into the cr3 uh that
phenotype is obviously not that robust
but the 601 of the fractal con also
again an immunoprotective molecule
when you don't have six cl1 63cl1
signaling
you do get much worse asthma uh and
there's a there's a hyperinflammatory
event that goes on there
and so clearly there's something going
on from a regulatory standpoint but uh
with that
so just to wrap up the last slide i have
here just
thanks all the members of the steel lab
former and current that
have worked on these projects uh i was
at uab for 11 years before coming to
tulane
two and a half years ago so i've got a
lot of collaborators there uh
the madame union and kaiser provided a
variety of mice uh colleagues at wake
forest university of arizona who are
clinical colleagues
uh in our severe asthma research program
research uh and then steve van dyken is
a new collaborator at washington
university who is an expert in chitin
biology
he's helping us uh figure out some of
the mechanisms associated with chitin
recognition and
cotton accumulation in the lawn um i
think that's it for me
um i'm gonna escape out of out of this
and go back to the
video a little bit longer than i
anticipated but
i think i got through what i wanted to
get through um
let's see you can hear me
yes we can hear you dr steele thank you
for your informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
so if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i see we have about
three or four
in right now our first question dr
steele
what role does one's epigenetics play in
genetic asthma if so are there any
environmental factors to be mindful of
that could possibly decrease one's
asthma severity
yeah that's a great question you know
and uh you would think i'd be the
perfect person to ask
this and i'm the first person to say
that i am not a geneticist
i'm an immunologist and um i mean there
there's quite a lot of data on
epigenetics in the role of plays
uh and definitely environmental um you
know factors
um as far as you know how do we use that
from a therapeutic standpoint or a
treatment option standpoint i can't tell
you to be honest with you um
it's definitely not my area it's not an
area that we actually look at
in my lab um but there is some data that
suggests
you know that you know you know
methylation status and things like that
could definitely modulate severity of
disease and so but
uh but just to be completely transparent
i'm just not the one to answer the
question
thank you dr steele um the next question
i have coming in
is asthma medicine um equally effective
like adults you know
i'm not a clinician i don't treat you
know patients um
but uh you know i guess my understanding
is yeah i mean you know
obviously i would argue that you know we
you know the clinical trials are more
adult slanted if you will i mean um and
so we have more data uh
in adults um you know we've often
wondered you know if we were to you know
model
our asthma experimental model in a
younger mouse versus an older mouse
would that give differences
as far as inflammation and things like
that um
but it does appear you know it's it's
not extremely common to break out a
pediatric population from an adult
population
um the severe asthma research program
actually did that
um and and there's some overlaps and
there's some distinctions actually
between the two populations but
um but yeah i i think if
in general yeah i think they would they
would be efficacious but i just think
the data is
much more robust and recognizing the
adult population than they are in the uh
in the kids population as far as some of
the biologic therapeutics you know and
things like that
obviously everybody has an inhaler or
you know whether you're young or or old
older you know adult
um as well as um
you know uh oral corticosteroids or
inhale corticosteroids those are
used pretty regularly in both adults and
pediatrics for just regular everyday
maintenance of
disease uh and so some of these are
probably a little bit more
wider and and broader therapeutic
efficacy than some of the other
targeted therapeutics like the biologics
and things like that
wonderful and we're going to wrap up
with this final question here
um as for genetic asthma do we have a
solution
yeah actually this was posted earlier i
think and i saw that before i started
and um i guess
i'm not completely clear on the actual
question i mean you know obviously
you know one of the major um uh goals of
the star program
you know and specifically the wake
forest site was
to um really phenotype asthma
genetically and look at polymorphisms
and
uh snips and things like that to really
understand and clearly they're
definitely definitely uh steps and all
kinds of things that correlate with
severity and you know things like that
um but you know
do we you know does that mean that we
have a you know
a therapeutic um you know not specific
based on on the genetic analysis i mean
you know again it really goes back to
our endotyping of the asthma
you know knowing what your triggers are
uh you know really knowing what
type of asthma you have is it the type
two is it the possible acidic is it
eosinophilic
knowing those can help us do precision
medicine or personalized medicine with
the therapeutics that we have
but you know there's you know biomarkers
that are coming out
now um that you know might
end up being better markers and better
targets than we've had
in the past um and maybe you know could
hit more specific types of asthma rather
than
you know the broader you know type 2
types and again this is really kind of
what drives our researches
trying to really understand um
um you know some of the biomarkers in
disease pathogenesis
uh specifically the fungi that we can
potentially harness
and use as a target for further
development
great thank you we actually have one
more question coming in if you'd like to
take it dr steele
um asthma is an immune deficiency
correct what can one with asthma do
in a time like we are in now with covid
that affects those with compromised
immune systems
i guess i don't really consider asthma
an immune deficiency per se
because a lot of time it's a
hypersensitivity or an allergic reaction
so you can almost think of it as
you know it's not autoimmune but it's a
hyperactive immune response to whatever
you're allergic to so i wouldn't call it
uh deficiency um
as far as you know asthma and
coronavirus um
there is an association it's actually um
uh it does appear to be a comorbidity
it's not as high as some of the other
ones that we're seeing diabetes and
hypertension
i know here in louisiana we're actually
tracking this and roughly
for what we could tell about four
percent of our coronal virus patients or
asthmatics
um so a low number but there is some
level of a correlation
um you know there's other lung diseases
that you know um
that you know can be confused with
asthma or overlap with asthma you know
chronic constructive pulmonary disease
is one that has a similarity to asthma
as well as
extinction from asthma you know and we
really you know don't know i mean
there's actually some data that suggests
that if you had asthma
and influenza um you actually uh do a
little bit better
so asthma is almost i don't say it's
protective but it's actually
um you know there's something going on
you know that that helps with influenza
rather than
hurts or adds on to disease severity now
whether we have that with covin
i i don't know it's something that we
would definitely be interested in
pursuing but as of right now the rates
are so low
from the standpoint of asthma is the
comorbidity um
you know it may not be you know worth
looking at but it is an interesting
question
thank you again dr steele for your time
today and your important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and their
interesting questions
i'd also like to thank our sponsor
luminex for sponsoring today's
webinar questions we did not get time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time
of your registration this webcast can
also be viewed on demand
for six months until march of 2021
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for
replay and we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live
event until next time thank you so much
again dr steele goodbye
yeah absolutely thank you